at least one of us knows who wrote
inside I know Jerry I know what a jerk
Blake Shelton's competitive side is
showing as he Dukes it out with his wife
Gwen Stefani on The Voice I think anyone
that knows me who knows I'm not really
that competitive I don't really play
games it all went down during the blind
auditions when contestant Austin
Montgomery wowed the coaches with his
performance of a country classic
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the 19 year old earns three chair
turns from Gwen Blake and first time
coach Camila Cabello and as they battled
it out Blake couldn't help but bring up
Gwen and Camila's lack of country
knowledge you want to go first you want
to go first go ahead I did turn first
but go ahead
Austin yes sir I think it would be very
important if you would ask the three of
us
who sings that song you just performed
what a jerk I
I at least one of us knows who wrote
inside but Gwen she doesn't take it
personal because in a turn of events she
actually supports Austin picking Blake I
think I could coach you really really
well because you have so much character
and so much style that's something that
I could probably do really well but
musically if you don't pick me
don't pick Camila okay
[Music]
I'm being real here guys this is your
career yeah this is your career
right there oh man this is awesome
no he loves what you do so do I well
third tactic ultimately worked as Austin
went with his gut and Gwen's and chose
Team Blake he belongs with you he does
the reason there's four coaches on The
Voice is because it takes three people
to go against me ah everybody can say
that about themselves but
so I'm normally you know
mounting my defense against three people
but now she's in there and so I kind of
have to play you know right it's it's
strategic
sure the competition is heating up but
it's nothing but love between the
sheltons during the blind auditions Gwen
even asked this big question how come
they never put me and Blake next to each
other it is weird because Blake we're
married now like we've never been on the
show since we've been married Camila of
course sits in the spot in between the
loved Birds she and fellow coach John
Legend speculate why the pair needs to
be separated while filming too much
trouble you guys can't resist each other
Keep Your Hands to Yourself
foreign